[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
12 juillet 2017
il fait nuit noire une frêle embarcation
en bois vient de prendre la mer elle
s'éloigne des côtes libyennes
à son bord une centaine de passagers
sont entassés essentiellement des hommes
jeunes beaucoup n'ont jamais vu la mer
pour la plupart ils ne savent pas nager
et ils ne portent pas de gilet de
sauvetage
au bout de quelques heures de navigation
le moteur tombe en panne
la barque dérive les voyageurs sont
perdus effrayé sans aucun repère dans
l'immensité noir de la méditerranée
parmi eux
recroquevillé à l'arrière du bateau se
trouve constance elle a 22 ans
elles voyagent seuls et cette nuit là
devant une centaine d'inconnus
elle est sur le point d'accoucher
[Musique]
il est 6 heures du matin quand les
marins sauveteurs de ssf méditerranée
repère de loin dans leurs jumelles
plusieurs petits bateaux en détresse
l'alerté donnée au pas de course il
enfile casque combinaison gillet les
canots de sauvetage sont mises à l'eau
c'est le début de l'après midi
depuis le matin les sauvetages
s'enchaînent la mairie calme il fait un
soleil de plomb
il règne un grand silence dans
l'embarcation au constance il ya déjà
plusieurs heures a donné la vie des
hommes l'aide à se lever
rocco le pilote du canot de sauvetage
est sans doute le premier à croiser son
regard et et n'oubliera jamais cette
image
la mère et le bébé sont toujours relié
par le cordon ombilical
il faut les faire passer de la barque
aux canaux tous les deux en même temps
tout ça sur l'eau avec les deux bateaux
qui bouge l'opération est très délicate
tout le monde regarde et retient son
souffle
une fois mise en sécurité sur le
zodiaque ils sont conduits à bord de
l'aquarius abord une sage-femme les
accueillent elle les accompagne dans la
clinique et enfin peut les séparer
en coupant le cordon christ est le
cinquième bébé né à bord du navire
ambulances de sos méditerranée et
médecins sans frontières après alex
newman five eux et merci pour les
équipes c'est à chaque fois un petit
miracle au coeur d'un drame annoncé au
total ce jour-là 860 personnes seront
secourus puis débarquer dans un port sûr
en italie comme moi vous demandez
peut-être ce qui a pu pousser une si
jeune femme enceinte a traversé la
méditerranée dans de telles conditions
l'histoire de constance je n'en connais
que quelques bribes rapportée par un
photographe bruno faire embarquer sur
l'aquarius en juillet 2017
son abandon par son père sa rencontre
avec son compagnon dont elle a ensuite
été séparé la détention en libye
les mauvais traitements qui lui ont été
infligées la nuit où elle a réussi à
échapper à ses geôliers
ce témoignage fait partie des milliers
recueillis à bord de l'aquarius depuis
le début des opérations en février 2016
erythrée soudan nigeria
les naufragés secourus en méditerranée
centrale sont pour la plupart
originaires d'afrique subsaharienne
ils ont fui un conflit armé une
dictature le terrorisme une grande
instabilité politique ou économique
une situation de maltraitance ou un
mariage forcé certains ont vécu des mois
voire des années dans un camp de
réfugiés aux conditions très précaires
là bas aucune opportunité de poursuivre
des études
et pas moyen de gagner de l'argent pour
subvenir aux besoins de la famille
restée au pays
alors ils ont décidé de partir et bien
que conscient d'une partie des risques
encourus
ils ont entrepris un voyage
long et périlleux avant d'arriver en
libye ils ont dû parcourir des milliers
de kilomètres à travers le continent
africain
traverser le désert du sahara où la
température peut atteindre 50 degrés
quand les camionnettes tombe en panne
des passeurs sans scrupules abandonnent
leurs passagers dans le désert sans eau
ni nourriture et ceux qui par malchance
tomberaient également surchargé ne sont
que rarement récupérer contrairement aux
idées reçues
tous n'ont pas au départ l'intention
d'aller en europe
loin de là un représentant des nations
unies rappelé l'an passé que 64% des
personnes arrivées en libye avaient
atteint leur destination finale
ce riche pays pétrolier a toujours
constitué une source importante
d'emplois pour les travailleurs migrants
notamment dans le secteur du bâtiment
mais une fois en libye beaucoup sont
kidnappé et séquestré dans des centres
tenus par des bandes armées ou des
milices reconverti dans le juteux trafic
d'êtres humains
ils sont réduits au travail forcé
tortures et pour obtenir une rançon
leurs familles affamées et parfois
vendus comme esclaves
la plupart des femmes et des jeunes
filles sont victimes de violences
sexuelles et de viol on le sait moins
mais beaucoup d'hommes et de garçons le
sont aussi
sept cent mille migrants sont encore
coincés en libye aujourd'hui un pays qui
depuis un mois connaît une nouvelle
explosion de violence armée parmi eux 45
mille relève de la convention de genève
de 1951 c'est à dire qu'ils sont
éligibles au statut de réfugié mais en
libye ce statut n'est pas reconnu alors
pour quitter cet enfer ils n'ont souvent
qu'une issue la méditerranée
cette nuit du 12 juillet 2007 quand les
pacers ont crié à constance et aux
autres voyageurs de courir vers les
barques en bois
beaucoup ont hésité à le faire ces
bateaux ne ressemblait en rien à ce
qu'on leur avait annoncé la dangerosité
de la traversée devenait évidente
comment espérer atteindre l'autre rive
de la méditerranée sur de tels
embarcation surchargée sans capitaine
sans gilet de sauvetage avec si peu
d'eau de nourriture et de fioul mais il
ne pouvait plus reculer
il avait payé la somme difficilement
collectées ne seraient pas rendues et
les récalcitrants se ferait battre
peut-être à battre on leur a dit de se
diriger droit devant pour sortir
rapidement des eaux territoriales
libyennes de viser les lumières qu'on
distingue assez facilement à l'horizon
que l'italie n'était qu'à trois heures
de navigation
mais ils ont vite réalisé que ces
lumières n'était autre que celle de
plate forme pétrolière en plein air est
ce qu'on ne leur avait pas dit c'est
qu'en réalité il leur faudrait trois à
cinq jours pour atteindre le port sur le
plus proche à condition de savoir
naviguer et d'avoir une embarcation
adapté et que sans secours il ne
pourrait jamais arriver
ces cinq dernières années près de vingt
mille personnes des hommes des femmes
des enfants ont ainsi péri noyées en
méditerranée
c'est parce qu'il n'est pas acceptable
de laisser mourir des êtres humains aux
portes de l'europe que klaus vaughn
capitaine de marine marchande allemand
et sophie bot humanitaires françaises
ont décidé de créer ensemble une
association civile européenne de
sauvetage en mer elle souhaite
méditerranée avec une poignée d'autres
citoyen j'ai répondu à leur appel en
2015 début 2015 et je me suis lancé dans
l'aventuré
j'ai moi-même auparavant travaillé
plusieurs années dans l'humanitaire mais
aujourd'hui je ne suis plus sur le
terrain je ne suis pas marrant je ne
sauve pas des vies en mer mais avec
d'autres salariés et plusieurs centaines
de bénévoles des citoyens engagés
je contribue à une autre mission de
l'association mission essentielle aussi
témoigné informer et sensibiliser le
grand public aux drames humains qui se
joue en méditerranée on s'adresse
notamment aux plus jeunes dans les
établissements scolaires c'est
particulièrement motivant ils sont
curieux avides d'informations et pendant
nos séances de sensibilisation les
questions fusent l'une d'elles est
récurrente
face à la situation que vous décrivez
pourquoi les états européens ne font-ils
rien faut revenir quelques années en
arrière 3 octobre 2013
un chalutier chaviré au large de l'île
de lampedusa faisant 3 166 victimes 500
personnes y avaient été entassés le
drame se produit à l'aube tout près des
côtes siciliennes et l'émotion est si
forte au sein de l'opinion publique que
le gouvernement italien décide de mettre
en place une opération de sauvetage à
grande échelle une opération militaire
et humanitaire baptisé marenostrum notre
mère elle permet en moins d'un an de
sauver 150 mille vies mais en octobre
faute de soutien des autres états
européens l'italie décide d'y mettre fin
et depuis il n'existe plus de moyens
étatiques dédié à la recherche et au
sauvetage des embarcations en mer
pourtant en novembre 2014
depuis les côtes turques et africaine
des personnes continuent à prendre la
mer au péril de leur vie
et l'hiver suivant sera le plus
meurtrier de l'histoire de la
méditerranée
malgré l'urgence humanitaire en
méditerranée l'europe ne déploie
toujours pas de moyens adéquats et
coordonnée pour porter secours aux
naufragés et les conduire dans un lieu
sûr et pire elle criminalise les
organisations non gouvernementales de
secours en mer les accusant de créer un
appel d'air
la présence de bateaux civils dans les
eaux internationales au large de la
libye
ainsi très des clandestins à se mettre
en danger mais aussi on dire de
l'ambiance qu'elle encourage les
accidents de la route
toutes les ong de secours en mer font
l'objet de diffamation de harcèlement
administratif de poursuites judiciaires
bateau mis sous séquestre pavillon
retirer équipage accusé d' aide à
l'immigration clandestine et même de
complicité avec les passeurs pourtant
l'assistance à personne en danger en mer
comme à terre est un devoir
et c'est de ne pas tendre la main qui
est criminel et quand on remet en cause
ce devoir d'assistance
c'est lé fondement même de nos sociétés
qu'on remet en cause l'humanité la
fraternité le respect de la dignité
humaine ne sont elles pas autant de
valeurs fondatrices de l'union
européenne la méditerranée centrale est
devenue une zone de non droit car le
droit maritime international y est
bafouée en toute impunité fermeture des
ports italiens aux personnes secourues
au large de la libye
illégal refoulement des rescapés vers
l'enfer qui tentait justement de fuir
illégal appui logistique et financier
des états de l'union européenne aux
autorités maritimes libyenne
inacceptables inacceptables quand on
sait que des garde-côtes libyens ont mis
délibérément en danger la vie de ce
qu'ils étaient censés se courir en mer
en les repoussant à l'eau et en les
menaçant de leurs armes
et quand on recueille le témoignage de
rescapés nous expliquant que ceux qui
les avaient interceptés en mer étaient
bien souvent
qui les avait mises à l'eau alors
comment expliquer aux adolescents que
nous rencontrons dans les collèges et
les lycées de france que nos dirigeants
tout en qualifiant le trafic organisé
d'êtres humains et l'esclavagé en libye
de crimes contre l'humanité poursuivre
leur politique de soutien à ceux là même
qui les perpétuent
la forte réduction des capacités de
recherche et de sauvetage en
méditerranée ont conduit à une
augmentation dramatique du taux de
mortalité
aujourd'hui ceux qui embarquent depuis
une plage de libye ont une chance sur
huit de périr noyés l'an passé 2300
personnes des hommes des femmes et des
enfants se sont noyés en tentant de
rejoindre l'europe
que nous le voulions ou non nous sommes
tous confrontés à cette tragédie humaine
en méditerranée et nul ne peut l'ignorer
avec l'aquarius nos équipes ont pu
porter secours à près de trente mille
personnes au cours de deux cent
cinquante opération menée sans relâche
pendant près de trois ans nous avons dû
renoncer à l'aquarius mais nous
repartirons avec un nouveau bateau dès
que possible pour poursuivre coûte que
coûte notre mission sauver des vies
protéger les rescapés et témoigner il
n'est pas besoin d'être marin médecin ou
sages femmes pour agir chacun d'entre
nous à son niveau peut contribuer à
sauver des vies en mer vous vous
demandez comment les traversées les
naufrages se poursuivent en méditerranée
ne détournez pas le regard parlez-en
autour de vous à vos enfants à vos
parents à vos amis à vos collègues
rejoignez nos équipes de bénévoles pour
participer à la sensibilisation et à la
mobylette à la mobilisation citoyenne
faites un don pour contribuer aux coûts
d'affrètement du nouveau bateau et aux
opérations de sauvetage
tous ces gestes et toutes ses attentions
sont autant de mains tendues vers ceux
qui risquent quotidiennement leur vie
dans l'espoir d'un avenir meilleur
en fait
c'est avant tout une question de choix
choisissons nous de rester spectateur ou
choisissons-nous d'être citoyen un an
après son sauvetage en mer nous avons eu
des nouvelles de constance parti
d'italie
elle avait franchi le col de l'échelle
son bébé dans les bras
à plus de 1700 mètres d'altitude pour
rejoindre la france
j'ai oublié de vous dire que constance
venait du cameroun
mais est-ce que cela a vraiment de
l'importance pour les sauveteurs qui lui
ont tendu la main ce 12 juillet 2010 est
en pleine mer ce n'était ni une
camerounaise ni une réfugiée ni une
migrante
c'était juste une personne en détresse
en mer quelles que soient nos
différences nous partageons avec
constance et tous les rescapés
un seul et même sentiment un sentiment
intense un sentiment précieux un
sentiment universel celle envie de vivre
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]